welcome to this video would say dot-com
seed are count to six and I never played
this guy from Israel very high rating to
five six nine let's see is even name
I am Gabrielle but time but Eileen II
from France
okay so I played g3 against the zone
let's see if I'm able to remember my own
recommendation drop the book Queen b6
yeah this was one one line
okay let's see I just hope to harass him
a bit
provoking weaknesses of possible yeah
but in fact Ribisi wanna serve as a
normal movement okay it's not it's not a
big problem
I am always able to return to a hedgehog
with Bishop e7 t six and so on at least
the skip some irritated for for the
moment okay let's see Ruby eight and
then maybe we treat later and then D six
f4 f5 this is sometimes an idea not sure
that it's valid exactly in this position
just look like it me maybe I'm even able
to play b5 this is in fact interesting I
mean it's not clear that I need to
resort
that's an interesting move I don't
understand it but it but it's
interesting coincidence your point look
I can I can get all the pawns to
understand what he's doing
hmm okay 123 I can always take c4 I can
can eat over the pawns I don't
understand it
what I'm a bit cautious about look at my
pieces yeah route d8 undefended b8
undefended not undefended this is the
well-known John Nam line loose piece
drop off and therefore I'm a bit
cautious but I don't see how he would
engineer any attacks on those pieces my
teeth
Queen Queen d4 I want to attack the
knight I can just go back to c6 on 2g
sexy yeah probably
wait wait wait wait wait knight c6 he
can maybe take and play Queen a7 die
afraid of you yeah then this is just
good attacking the Queen okay so now b3
hangs oh yeah but I don't really I don't
really need to take it and it serve it's
tricky look b1 or whatever I can just go
back here this a3 problem is just
something that I should should take and
be happy with okay let's see d5 maybe 95
okay I'll drop back here he can't play
96 but this is not not the perfect
locate I can play here and maybe just
take it I have a 5 LB 5
various ways to to attack it
let's check b5 the Queen doesn't really
have squares and still still okay from
everything else fails ago Queen eight
five two system to consolidate
between what's the idea not h5 or
something oh okay I'll go I'll follow
that plan
Wow okay
yeah this is the kind of stuff that the
computer laughs at afterwards but it's
not easy not easy to defend check should
be four maybe I don't know yeah
it's not so not so clear-cut
my queen is some foul this is some the
typical problem of many attacks that the
defending queen is away c6 could be him
could be a big problem
something like that intending c7 and I'm
not sure I can take it
yeah this is a very simple move but
maybe good a good one hmm it's not
threatening a maid down I always have e7
to escape
check
I'm threatening rook h8 winning and I
don't see he must play something he does
not want to play they should retreat or
something yeah yeah well this is just
winning now but I can always blunder it
of course this makes the position much
more yeah easier to play check check
check check
white resigned yeah I don't think this
was working really the sacrifice maybe
I'm wrong but it's you know that's the
same men around here I'm a pawn up he
needs to do something drastic
try the cops sy doin Sam yeah the the
Queen the Queen this there is something
Queen Cathleen h5 this is what he did
what is winning here rook g6 winning
yeah this is winning I'm not quite sure
why what does this move actually doing
96
yeah he's right a tree what's the threat
I don't know
whoops yeah well trickier what how does
it continue the cop wants to play rugby
7 and then gives a check and then this
one yeah maybe just threatening 96 and
and c6 and stuff and I'm all tied up
here I don't have that I don't have any
move so this means some I should have
played differently I mean I'm pretty
sure that I'm just I'm just an excellent
shape at this position just need to be
precise and I am probably this one I
played I played this move I must
probably play d6 preventing c5 and in
those ideas
the queen is also controlling g5 yeah
this is excellent I'm already a pawn up
and it's an important pawn that keeps
the Queen side together so the structure
is also excellent yeah this is probably
right or instead of the Queen move there
was this and then d6 getting to the head
shock but I'm already a corner for this
a3 pawn you know nobody in him he got
two very dangerous attack in fact a
winning attack so Knight f7 was a nice
point I was under estimating this and it
was still winning
funny enough check for wins but Queen h7
is the Queen f7 Jeff honey enough spoils
it completely - and gives black the
better game okay rook deforested wrong
hope defy for typical computer chess he
did this and now it's CERN it's gone
yeah this is just the easiest mopping up
the game with the two bishops
raging across the board all right an
interesting game thanks for watching